there's this whole branch of Statistics
out there called survival analysis also
known as time to event analysis so what
exactly is this and when should you use
it well in this video I'm going to cover
that I'm Richard and this is Richard on
data so over the years survival analysis
is one of the approaches that I've come
back to and used the most personally
probably more so than any other method
other than say regression models a lot
of that has to do with the industries
I've worked in because I've spent most
most of my working life so far in
healthcare and Pharma and in those
Industries and several others survival
analysis is applicable to a ton of
different problems so in this video I'm
going to cover what it even is the type
of data and real world use cases in
which it's applicable some of the key
Concepts and some of the most common
methods if all that sounds good to you
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and take just a fraction of a
second to smash the like button cuz it
really helps me get noticed by the
YouTube algorithm so let's start with
the most foundational question which is
what exactly is survival analysis in the
first place well broadly speaking it's a
branch of Statistics that helps us when
we're interested in the time until some
event of Interest occurs there are all
kinds of applications of this more
generally think of any event where given
enough time it's going to happen the
most obvious example is right there in
the name survival until we die which we
all do there's plenty of other examples
in healthcare you could have time until
relapse or until some other sort of
significant medical event occurs and for
marketing it could be customer churn or
time until your customer stops using
your product or service here's a pretty
instructive real world example so this
is a good one out there from the State
University at courland looking at
survival time and probabilities of
patients from that sickness that started
in late 2019 early 2020 and the effect
that things like time in a ventilator
the patient's age and various patient
comorbidities have UNS survival
probability so you might be wondering
we're working with a binary outcome here
so why do we even need this field of
methods like why can't we just use
logistic regression or some kind of ml
algorithm for classification well for
one thing these methods generally don't
incorporate time as a center piece time
is a crucial factor in survival analysis
and as you'll see it allows us to
estimate survival probability over time
and the other huge thing is survival
analysis helps us account for what's
known as sensored data so what's sensor
data well there's two main kinds of
sensor data that is right sensored and
left sensored and right sensored is by
far the more common of the two so with
right sensor data that usually occurs
when somebody prematurely withdraws from
the study or the study just has to come
to a close you know that the subject
hasn't experienced that event up to that
point in time but you don't know when
eventually they're going to experience
it now with left sensor data it's a
different situation so you know the
subject has experienced the event before
some time point you just don't know
exactly when so let's look at some
examples of these two here's an example
from mini tab here the study is on
pregnant women and the event in question
is having their baby so let's say on one
hand we're finishing up the study and we
need to analyze the data let's say for
patient five over here we observe them
from 293 days and there's still no baby
that's a very long pregnancy we know the
pregnancy will last longer than 293 days
we just don't know how much so that's an
example of right sensor data but then on
the other hand suppose we were analyzing
women who were at the 250 day Mark and
just based on how we collected the data
we know some of them already had their
babies we just don't know exactly on
what day they did that's an example of
left sensor data so a key to survival
analysis is what's known as the survival
function and that's what we're going to
estimate through some of these methods
and the idea here is estimate by
sometime T what the probability of
experiencing or not experiencing the
event by that time T is often we're
interested in what's known as the median
survival which is the time at which the
survival probability has fallen to 50%
it's probably easiest to illustrate this
with some examples now the visualization
of this is known as the Kaplan Meyer
curve now this is an example from the
Boston University School of Public
Health the outcome they're tracking here
is onset of dementia and there are two
different groups one group is elderly
people who frequently played board games
such as chess Checkers back Amon or
cards at a baseline time and the other
is people who rarely played such games
so you've got time on the x- axis and
the survival probability on the Y AIS
that gives us a probability of surviving
in this case free of dementia up to that
point or later more on this later but
since the played frequently group is
fully on the outside of the played
rarely group it looks like the played
frequently group is doing better and if
we're interested in the median survival
time just eyeball a horizontal line from
the survival probability around 0.5 that
would mean that after about 8 years or
so 50% of the played rarely group gets
dementia but it takes maybe about 12 to
13 years for 50% of the played
frequently group to get dementia so
unfortunately the analysis of this is a
little bit more rigorous than simply
eyeballing a graph and deciding one
function looks a little bit more on the
outside than the other well that's where
something called The Log rank test comes
in and before I talk about that one
other function we need to think about is
what's known as the hazard function in
simple terms this function measures the
probability of the event occurring in an
infinitesimally small time interval
given that the subject has already
survived up to that point basically the
higher this function the more risk or
the more Hazard the subject is in and
this is inversely related to the
survival function so with a log rank
test we're comparing different groups
our null hypothesis assumes that the
different groups have identical Hazard
functions now putting that another way
if the groups have identical Hazard
functions they would have identical
survival functions so under this null
hypothesis the test statistic we use has
a Ki Square distribution and here's
another link from Boston University with
more detail about this and you can read
this in more detail but essentially when
we compute this test statistic it relies
on calculating The observed and expected
number of events over time assuming the
null hypothesis is true and if you
reject the null hypothesis you conclude
that the hazard function of one group is
different from the other so to this
point we've covered the survival and
Hazard functions comparing groups using
a log rank test and eyeballing their
survival functions using a Kaplan Meyer
curve survival analysis is also rich
with many different types of models so
the ones that are most similar to
Conventional ml methods are what's known
as survival trees or survival forests
which these are pretty fascinating in
their own right there's also parametric
examples a pretty common one being
what's known as The Accelerated failure
time model but the most famous example
of survival model and the last topic
that I'm going to cover in this video is
what's known as the Cox proportional
hazards model so if we're thinking about
this at a very high level the
proportional hazards model can be used
in a very similar way to something like
a logistic regression model you have one
or more variables and the model is going
to give you coefficients and tested
Statics for all of them using those we
can determine if the covariates have a
statistically significant relationship
with Hazard rate so this is all pretty
intuitive easy to use and
straightforward right well in most cases
yes but there is one major assumption
that we need to know about and that's
what's known as the proportional hazards
assumption so the proportional hazards
assumption states that the hazard ratio
between two individuals or groups stays
constant over time let's put that
another way so let's suppose you're
doing a study and you're looking at
subjects that took different treatments
if you find at the beginning of the
study that the hazard rate for subjects
who take treatment A is twice as high as
for subjects who take treatment B the
Assumption states that the hazard for
treatment a will remain twice as high
throughout the entire study that's a
pretty big assumption but it's also a
really important one so the model gets
really unreliable if this isn't the case
so this is definitely something you want
to be checking before you go creating a
proportional hazard's model but anyway
let's look at an example of this again
from Boston University this study's
outcome is all cause mortality between
men and women participating in the
Framingham heart study down here we have
the risk factors parameter estimates and
P values and starting with the p values
the interpretation is just like you'd
expect supposing you're using a 5%
significance level then a P value under
05 indicates that covariant has a
statistically significant relationship
with subject Hazard as far as the
parameter estimates go these estimate
the increase in the expected log of the
relative Hazard for each one unit
increase in that variable holding other
predictors constant that's easiest to
understand by exponentiating them so the
example they give here is by
exponentiating the age coefficient in
the upper table
01149 to get
1.18 so that means there's an
11.8% increase in the expected Hazard
relative to a one-year increase in age
holding everything else constant or to
make it even simpler positive
coefficients indicate higher risk
negative coefficients imply lower risk
risk so I'm going to leave you there
with the ideas behind survival analysis
hopefully you're getting the idea now
though that this is an incredibly Rich
branch of Statistics with tons to
explore in it there's tons of
applications of it and lots of things
that you can do and luckily in python or
R there's tons of packages for doing
exactly that the links of which will be
in the description but to summarize the
most important point if you're working
with some event that you can reasonably
assume will have happened to everyone
given enough time whether or not you
even observe this happening to everyone
in your data and the time until that
event occurs is interesting then
survival analysis is almost definitely
applicable to your problem so thanks for
watching this video If you enjoyed it
hit the like button if you didn't enjoy
it you're welcome to hit the dislike
button I suppose leave me a comment down
below and let me know what you think of
survival analysis do you love it has it
been useful for you do you hate it let
me know then I'll see you all in the
Noto distant future until then Richard
on data